[Music]
we see them on the TV and our computer
screens all the time
they're constantly in magazines and
they're one of the most talked-about
people on the planet
they have the look and they have the
attitudes these are the celebrities that
could be easily reimagined as cartoons
and some of them look exactly like some
of your favorite TV characters which
character do you think Selena Gomez
would play best if you enjoy our video
and want more click the subscribe button
now join us as we reimagine one of your
favorite celebrities as cartoon
characters Selena Gomez Selena Gomez is
without a doubt one of the most popular
and talked-about young singers on the
planet from her rocky relationships to
her beautiful voice and a very well
established career she certainly earned
her spot in a celebrity world but her
big eyes large hair and a beautiful
voice could easily land her a role in a
cartoon she could also pass as an
American Girl doll or a Bratz character
Rihanna of course we can't forget to
mention Rihanna the popular singer has
been leaving her mark on the Billboard
chart since 2005 and it looks like her
fan base continues to grow with many
looks rihanna sported over the years
which one do you think would best suit
her as a cartoon character her who's
that chick look perfectly fits a
powerful anime character Emma Stone Emma
Stone rose to popularity and became one
of the highest paying actresses in 2015
her bubbly personality is one of the
many things that sets her apart and we
love her sense of humor her cartoon
character with fiery red hair big green
eyes and a husky voice could very easily
fit in a cartoon like Kim Possible in
fact doesn't she actually look exactly
like Kim Possible Katy Perry Katy Perry
whose full name is Katherine Elizabeth
Hudson is always one of the most
talked-about Hollywood celebrities we
love her voice but we also adore her
fashion sense over the year she sported
many different styles we totally see her
as a crime-solving spy character who can
easily camouflage herself into
practically anything and we definitely
see her in a colorful cartoon world with
Kandy another out-of-this-world
decorations beyonce we can't leave out
the absolute queen bee can we beyonce
has been reimagined as a cartoon
character thousands of times and we're
in love with all these drawings from the
all dressed in black beyond safe
from her formation video back to the 90s
style Destiny's Child
what cartoon character do you think
Beyonce would play Nicki Minaj and of
course we have the second Queen Nicki
Minaj her beautiful looks could also
easily become a cartoon without a doubt
she would be playing right next to her
gal pal Beyonce do you think she would
wear her pink hair or her natural look
we love this cartoon drawing from her
anaconda video Dwayne the rock Johnson
the rock is known as an actor producer
singer but did you know he is also a
professional wrestler perhaps this is
exactly what landed him his role in the
latest Disney movie Moana where he
borrowed his voice to the overconfident
tattooed demigod Maui but someone also
thought the rock would look amazing as a
South Park character and made this
drawing kanye west from interrupting
Taylor Swift's acceptance speech to
having monologues at his own concerts
Kanye is unpredictable and his
personality sets him apart from the rest
of the world married to Kim Kardashian
the stylish rapper could also very
easily be a part of a cartoon world of
course his cartoon character was already
featured in shows like South Park but we
can see Kanye's personality perfectly
fit in with many other cartoon shows out
there Justin Bieber
tattooed or non tattooed Justin Bieber
would definitely be the bad boy of his
cartoon show just like many other
celebrities on our list Justin Bieber
was also portrayed in the popular
cartoon show South Park although his
South Park storyline isn't exactly a
happy one we think Justin Bieber could
be reimagined as a cartoon Jennifer
Lawrence from the shape-shifting
mystique in x-men - everyone's favorite
Hunger Games fighter Katniss Everdeen
Jennifer Lawrence is one of the most
popular names in the past few years but
it's her fantastic sense of humor and
her bubbly extroverted personality that
would make her an amazing cartoon
character many have pointed out that she
looks exactly like Luanne platter from
king of the hill ariana grande with her
adorable looks in her powerful voice
ariana grande would make a perfect
cartoon character the dangerous woman
singer has been drawn many times and we
absolutely love her long hair and big
eyes even her role as Cat Valentine on
Victorious could easily be turned into a
cartoon show at her cat ears and her
seven dogs and you're guaranteed to have
an exciting cartoon Taylor Swift blonde
outspoken beautiful voice and a guitar
in her
and Taylor Swift has been portrayed as a
cartoon character many times we love all
cartoon drawings the shake it off singer
has transformed her looks many times
over the years we definitely see her
cartoon character placed in a school
with her guitar as her secret power
Adele the powerful singer has plenty of
impersonators and we bet she would do an
amazing job as a cartoon character
can you see Adele in a cartoon show we
bet she would be singing but who knows
it turns out Adele has many secret
talents perfect for cartoon show did you
know that she can rap we can definitely
imagine Adele is a graceful cartoon
character with a secret weapon which is
her voice Maddie Ziegler this pint-sized
dancer is taking the world by storm
Maddie Ziegler is one of the most
talked-about teenagers on the planet
Time magazine named her as one of the
world's most influential teenagers her
dancing is breathtaking but it takes a
whole new level whenever she puts on her
seal wig
do you see Maddie Ziegler as a cartoon
show she recently borrowed her voice to
an animated movie ballerina
fifth harmony fifth harmony has been
climbing the charts
ever since the group was formed on
x-factor their outgoing personalities
and incredible voices are what makes
them stand out we really think these
girls would make fantastic Girl Power
cartoon characters in fact the group is
so popular they already have quite a few
fan made cartoon drawings check these
out Little Mix Little Mix the British
girl group band is also taking the music
charts by storm the band has a large fan
base and has been previously compared to
the famous pop girl group Spice Girls
Perry Jessie Jade and LeAnn come with
distinctive looks big eyes and plenty of
amazing hair that would look great in a
cartoon who thinks they could easily
portray the Bratz dolls Neil Patrick
Harris from Robot Chicken and Adventure
Time to the Penguins of Madagascar and
even Batman Neil Patrick Harris has
borrowed his voice to quite a few
cartoon characters over the years but we
think he'd make a perfect cartoon
character himself it's been noted that
he's quite a look-alike to the Riddler
the character in Batman the Animated
Series Michael Moore Michael Moore is a
filmmaker and the man behind many
provoking documentaries many people have
reported he actually resembles family
guys very own Peter Griffin what do you
think could you picture Michael Morin
family guy or is there any other
cartoons he'd be perfect in Blake Lively
this Gossip Girl star
has long blonde hair and a
million-dollar smile perfect for cartoon
character we can see her character
playing in a fun anime series she's been
previously compared to the Sailor Moon
character and some even say she looks
like Princess Aurora from Sleeping
Beauty although with her long hair she
could also portray a Rapunzel character
what do you think Gabby Douglas gymnast
extraordinaire Gabby Douglas is a force
to be reckoned with the charismatic
teenagers easily a favorite gymnast but
we think she could also easily pass as a
cartoon character her contagious
personality and her charming smile have
been compared to Princess Tiana from
Princess and the Frog
Gabby could easily be reimagined as a
cartoon character who's super strong
Angelina Jolie the Academy award-winning
actress has been a part of the Hollywood
elites and starring in Lara Croft Tomb
Raider back in 2001 her distinctive
looks could easily make her an excellent
cartoon villain she previously portrayed
a vengeful fairy in a 2014 movie
Maleficent but don't you think she also
looks like the Queen from Snow White Zac
Efron Zac Efron rose to popularity with
the cheery High School Musical trilogy
and he's still one of the most popular
cast members from singing dancing and
acting there's nothing Zac Efron can't
do which is why he'd make a perfect
cartoon character he even looks like
Cyclops from x-men and has previously
borrowed his voice to several cartoon
characters including Ted from the Lorax
Nicole Scherzinger it's everyone's
favorite Pussycat Doll Nicole
Scherzinger could easily pass as a
Princess Jasmine with her long dark hair
and charming looks we see her as a
cartoon princess or even a villain
recently the multi-talented nicole
played a loving mother in a popular
Disney animated movie Moana and said one
of her dreams came true
do you see Nicole playing more cartoon
roles Martin Scorsese Martin Scorsese is
a famous film director that gets
reimagined as a cartoon character quite
frequently he's got pretty distinctive
features and his big glasses gray hair
and square shaped face already make him
cartoon leg in fact doesn't he look
exactly like Carl from up the
resemblance is uncanny he definitely has
a spot in the cartoon world Will Smith
The Fresh Prince of bel-air is without a
doubt one of the most cartoon eyes
person ever his outgoing and goofy
personality would fit into any car
tune just like many others on this list
he was also used as a cartoon
inspiration for South Park in 2004 he
also played Oscar the fish in Shark Tale
don't you think his personality and
smile resembles curse so much
Macklemore college humor perfectly
Illustrated how Macklemore would look
like if he ever had his own cartoon show
according to college humor Macklemore
would be a superhero named captain
Macklemore and he'd fight for social
justice and civil rights the internet
also pointed out Macklemore looks like
Doug funnies enemy Roger Klotz Benedict
Cumberbatch the beloved English actor is
most known for his role as Sherlock
Holmes he has also been announced as a
voice actor for the new animated movie
How the Grinch Stole Christmas but we
think Benedict would make an excellent
cartoon detective
do you remember beavis and butt-head
doesn't benedict resemble Butthead the
haircut the shape of the face we totally
see it Harry Styles famous for being in
one of the most popular modern boy bands
One Direction Harry Styles has quite a
big fan base it's so big the internet
actually reimagined him as many cartoons
including Bambi
Tarzan and Snow White it turns out the
popular singer has many cartoon
look-alikes his personality and looks
would be perfect for goofy and clumsy
cartoon character Russell Brand if there
ever was an inspiration needed for a
cartoon character
we're pretty sure Russell Brand would be
the perfect person the hair the crazy
outspoken personality the confident
attitude and a beautiful English accent
to boot it doesn't get better than
having Russell Brand cartoon eyes maybe
that's what landed him a role on The
Simpsons angry dad the movie episode
where he brilliantly portrayed himself
Miley Cyrus and what's even better than
the cartoon version of Russell Brand the
cartoon version of Miley Cyrus her
fashion statements combined with her
personality would make a perfect cartoon
character Miley has been cartoon eyes
plenty of times from flying on a
wrecking ball to portraying Hannah
Montana Miley has had many looks over
the years the internet also pointed out
she looks like Cynthia from the Rugrats
what do you think her cartoon show would
look like what's your favorite cartoon
let us know in the comments below and
don't forget to like this video
want more check out the video about 10
people who twin with Disney characters
by accident
[Music]